Herkese merhaba
eee fütürist bir de tekno
progresivo aklımda bir şey tutamıyorum
Eee şimdi gelecekle ilgili konuşma
yaptığınızda Eee uzgörü de
bulunduğunuzda herkes şunu sorgular Ya
tamam da geçmişte ne söyledin de ne oldu
yani hani bize bir şey ver de sana
inanalım diye önce babamdan başlıyorum
rahmetli Profesör Oz Manas Ege
Üniversitesi'nin bir numaralı öğrencisi
o 1991 yılında Eee Yeniasır gazetesi bir
röportaj yapmıştı o zaman internet yoktu
biliyorsunuz internet
1994'te 9 94'te başladı
www o zaman söylemişti ki oturduğumuz
yerden alışveriş yapacağız internet
alışverişi yapacağız bilgisayarlarla
rezervasyon yapacağız diye Dolayısıyla
ben de biraz babamın izninden yürüdüm
Eee Birkaç tanesini paylaşayım istedim
ama vaktimiz yok o yüzden hızlı
geçeceğim
Eee kaç yılıydı 2002 yılında Tempo
dergisi benimle röportaj yaptı e işte
gelecekle ilgili oradaki arkadaşım
röportaj yapan arkadaşım hatta
basmayalım dedi Bunu ben dedim ki beyin
dalgalarıyla ileride drone uçuracağız
dedim Eee o zaman drone diye bir kelime
yoktu daha farklı bir kelime vardı
Dolayısıyla 2015 yılında Florida
Üniversitesi'nde eee drone e uçm
uçurmaya başladılar beyin dalgalarıyla E
ondan O günden sonra da bu beyin
dalgalarına takmış durumdayım
anlatacağım size işte drone'lar da bu
hale geldi şimdi hakikaten Geleceği
tahmin etmek o kadar kolay değil hele
bundan sonra hiç değil değil diyelim ki
20 yıl sonrasını tahmin edelim gelin
önce bir 20 yıl öncesini tahmin edelim
bunların hiçbiri var mıydı 20 yıl önce
yoktu yani şimdi bunların olmadığı bir
dönemde biz Eee 20 yıl sonrasını tahmin
etmeye çalıştık Dolayısıyla bunların Eee
çok kolay olmadığını görüyoruz Eee Akşam
Gazetesi 2006 yılında benimle röportaj
yaptığında ileride arabalarımız da
yaşayacağımızı hatta bu arabalar
arabalarla işte eee yüksek Park
yerlerine Park ed diyeceğimizi ortak
alanları Eee diğer şeyler için
ihtiyaçlarımız için kullanacağımızı
söylemiştim
Eee 2000
2022 las vegas'taki
şeyde tüketici elektroniği fuarında LG
tanıtmaya başladı Yani bunu karavan
olarak görmeyin bunların ileride otonom
olduğunu düşünün Eee Dolayısıyla bu
otonom araçlar Eee siz aracın içinde Eee
seyahat ederken
eee E yani siz arabayı
kullanmayacaksınız Aslında seyahat
edeceksiniz Dolayısıyla o sizin bir
yaşam alanınız olacak bunlar da
yaşamımıza yavaş yavaş girmeye
başlayacaklar Avrupa uzaktan çalışmaya
başlıyor bunların bu aslında
istatistiklerin çoğu Eee covid önceydi
Eee % 27 deniyor 2030'a geldiğimde ben
bu rakamın çok daha fazla olduğunu
düşünüyorum Ayrıca daha da önemlisi
insanlar aynı anda iki İşte çalışmaya
başlayacaklar mesela Avrupa'daki 10 tane
ülke yerel ekonomilerini canlandırmak
için kendi ülkelerine sizi kabul etmek
ama şey olarak değil dijital Göçebe
olarak Eee kabul etmek isteyecekler size
para verecekler
Eee Bunlar bunlara bağlı olarak Göçebe
köyleri oluşacak Göçebe bu Göçebelik
nedir bir ondan bahsedeyim size dijital
Göçebe aynı zamanda seyahat eden aynı
zamanda yaşayan belirli bir e bölgede 36
ay arası kalan Aslında beyaz yakalı veya
kendi işini yapan kişiye Biz dijital
Göçebe diyoruz şimdi Eee Aslında dijital
Göçebelik Eee o kadar hızlı gelişecek ki
şöyle söyleyeyim Eee instant offices e
2022'de Eee dijital göçebeler le ilgili
En iyi yaşam alanlarını belirlemiş ilk
üçte Lizbon bangkong ve Selanik var
Selanik de İzmir'in rakibi biliyorsunuz
Bu anlamda çok da benzeşiyor neymiş Fiat
hava durumu geniş bantı airbnb
girerseniz aynı şekilde orada da dijital
göçebeliği göreceksiniz 205'e kadar 1
milyar kişinin dijital Göçebe olacağı
söyleniyor yani her ü çalışandan biri
dijital Göçebe olacak Dolayısıyla
ülkeler
artık dijital Göçebe köyleri kurmaya
başlayacaklar Eee şimdi Hani benim
konuşma başlığım da uymam gerektiği için
bir şeyler söyleyeyim istedim şöyle e
World economic Forum 2000 2025 yılında
Eee çok önemli yetkinlikler olması
gerektiğini söyledi Analitik düşünme ve
inovatif olma aktif öğrenme karmaşık
problem çözme teknolojik kullanımı
izleme ve kontrol ama bundan daha da
önemlisi yaratıcılık ve girişimcilik
Yani öyle bir yetkinliğimizin
de artık girişimcilik bir yetkinlik
içine girmiş durumda Peki eee Aramızda
bir tane üstün zekalı arkadaşım var
onunla beraberdim Mensa Mensa e dünyanın
en büyük üstün zekalılar Eee Derneği Ben
başkanlığını yapıyorum aynı zamanda
uluslararası yönetim kurulunda e
bulundum üstün zeka ile girişimcilik
arasında bir bağlantı olduğu tespit
edilmiş yaratıcılık Pratik Zeka ve
inovatif düşünce Bu Üstün zekayla
girişimci arasındaki bağlantıyı
görmüşler ve Hatta ve hatta dikkat
eksikliği ve hiperaktivite bozuklu
Olanların da Daha yaratıcı olduğu e
ortaya çıkmış Şimdi biz Eee Topkapı
Üniversitesi'nde beyin dalgalarını
kullanarak Eee IQ ölçümü yapabilecek bir
teknoloji üzerinde çalışıyoruz Eee
birkaç ülkeyle beraber yani Rusya
var İngiltere var İspanya var Şimdi bunu
yaparken şunu tespit ettik a Demek ki
biz aynı şekilde girişimciyi de tespit
edebiliriz Çünkü girişimci de aynı
şekilde girişimcilerin farklı beyin
aktiviteleri var Yani akıl yürütme
algılama karar verme ve problem çözmede
de reflektif olarak biz Eee girişimciyi
ölçebilecek durumdayız şimdi beyin
dalgaları dediğim gibi hani Eee Bundan
20 yıl önce bu beyin dalgalarına
taktığım için hala devam ediyorum bakın
Yunanlı araştırmacılar beyin dalgalarını
e tarayarak dinlediğimiz müziği sevip
sevmediğimizi Eee anlamaya başladılar
şimdi olay nereye gidiyor Harvard
Üniversitesi'nin yaptığı araştırmada
günümüzün % 47'si geçmiş ve bugünü
düşünmekle geçiyor Eee Dolayısıyla
geçmiş ve bugünü düşünüyor demek aslında
karamsarlığı oluşturuyor boş düşünce
Yani biz
Eee uykuda olmadığımız dönem içerisinin
sadece % 53'ün
Eee verimli olarak kullanabiliyoruz
şimdi Böyle olunca da uzaktan çalışan
Eee personeli nasıl takip edeceksiniz
juggler diye bir şey var Amazon'da
satılıyor bu Mouse un Arada bir böyle
oynamasını sağlıyor şimdi Eee
uluslararası firmalar personellerinin
evlerinde çalışıp çalışmadıklarına Mouse
hareketlerini Eee takip ederek
yapıyorlar ama şimdi onu da aldatması
çıktı sanki çalışıyormuş gibi jiggler
oynatmaya başlıyor mouse'u oynuyormuş
gibi gözüküyor Evet Eee Çin'de Eee
Deneme amaçlı başladı öğrencilerin
Eee öğrencilerin dikkatini ölçmek için
Eee gene beyin dalgalarını kullanıyorlar
yani dersine kadar eee Eee konsantre
olduklarını görebilmek için şimdi süper
akıllı toplum diye bir şey var biz
endüstri 4.0 dayız fakat Eee Biz ne
yazık ki Eee Society 5.0a e geçiyoruz
yani Society 0'la Aslında geldiğimiz
nokta süper akıllı toplum olmak
zorundayız Çünkü öyle bir gelişim
yaşanıyor ki süper akıllı bir toplum
olmadığınız takdirde burada çok büyük
bir sorun yaşayacaksınız Şimdi mesela
ABD'de hop süper akıllı toplum olabilmek
için dijital okur yazarlık gerekiyor bir
kere dijital okur yazarlık olmadan süper
akıllı bir toplum olma şansımız yok E
Amerika'da 65 yaşının üzerinde
Eee 65 yaşın üzerinde akıllı telefon
kullanımı % 61 sağlık uygulaması
kullananlar da onun % 28'i yani niye
sağlık uygulaması diyorum çünkü yani siz
yani
yaşlıysa Şey hani tinder
olmak değildir herhalde diye düşünüyorum
sağlık
uygulaması bakarsınız bakın Türkiye'de
Türkiye'nin yaş ortalaması 33 Eee ama
tarımda çiftçinin yaş ortalaması 55
Ondan sonra ortaya çıkıyorlar diyorlar
kiim tarımda çiftçimiz şey kullansın
işte teknoloji kullansın ya Nasıl
kullanacak yani 55 yaşında rakamsal
olarak böyle bir şey hayal kurmamıza
gerek yok Eee toplumun ıq'sunu da Yüksel
m i gerekiyor bakın bizim o dalga
geçtiğimiz beni Twitter'da takip edenler
bundan 4 önceki tweet'te görecekler e
Doğu batıdan daha zeki zaten Doğu O
yüzden de batıyı sollayıp geçecek yani
Singapur'un Hong Kong'un Çin'in Güney
Kore'nin ıq'sunu bakıyorsunuz
Türkiye'nin IQ'su 86. şu anda dünyada 76
sıradayız Demek ki ıq'm da yükseltmek
gerekiyor Neden ıq'm u yükseltmemiz
gerekiyor çünkü yapay zekayla başka
türlü mücadele edemeyiz yani yapay
zekaya Aksi takdirde şey yapamayız yapay
zekaya hiç girmeyeceğim Çünkü çok esnek
bir konu konuş konuş konuş sonsuza kadar
konuşu ama çok basit şöyle söyleyeceğim
size yani 2027 yıl 20 yılında 17 milyar
parametre ile çalışıyordu Eee 2023'e
geldiğimizde 100 trilyon parametreye
çıktı Yani yapay zekanın Eee parametre
sayısı arttıkça şeyi de artıyor
değerlendirme Hızı da artıyor Öğrenmeyi
de tabii Eee kullanarak Tan Biz yapay
zekanın ne kadar hızlı Neyi öğrendiğini
ve ne kadar hızlı büyüdüğünü artık
tahmin edemiyoruz O yüzden bugün yapay
zeka ile ilgili tek bir şey söyleyeceğim
ileride hayvanlarınız da konuşacaksınız
nokta başka bir şey söylememe gerek yok
Eee Dolayısıyla Peki yapay zekalar
yönetici olursa Oracle firması Eee
Future workplace ile beraber 2019'da bir
araştırma yaptı 10 ülkede
8300 yönetici işte eee ika lideri burada
çıkan sonuç çok enteresan çalışanların %
64'ü yapay zekaya yöneticilerinden daha
fazla güveniyorlar yani Neden Çünkü
çünkü
Eee yöneticilerinin hakkaniyetli ve
adaletli olmadığını düşünüyorlar
yöneticilerin çok fazla duygusal hareket
ettiklerini düşünüyorlar e Dolayısıyla
Yani biz biz diyorlar ki ya ben
yöneticimin çocukluğuna inmeyin ya Yani
onu da başkası yapsın yani Dolayısıyla
biz yöneticimiz çoc inmeden yapay
zekayla bu işi çözecek demiş gibi
gözüküyoruz 2004 yılında bir
konferansında işte geleceğin sağlığını
anlatmıştım Neydi bu sağlık aslında
noninvasive yani vücudunuza bir şey
girmeden nasıldır Bu baktığınızda
nefesten diyabet ve kanser retinadan
diyabet kanser glom
e yaklaşık
520 mililitre
Eee şu anda normal damardan kan alındığı
zaman sizde Test için
ml gerekiyor ama aslında 0.1 ml kan ile
bile artık test yapılabiliyor
Dolayısıyla bunu değdirdi de bir şey
batmadan otomatik kanı çekebiliyor
tükürükten HIV otoimmün hastalıkları
kalıtsal hastalıklar endokrin bozuklar
hepatit ABC idrar ve dışkıdan böbrek
artık bir yere Eczanede bir noktaya
gittiğinizde Eee bütün testlerin online
yapabilecek durumdasınız yani dış dan
tutun şeye kadar ve eczanede bu tip
kornalar olacak Ben de zaten konferansta
Onu söylemiştim ama 19 yıl önce söyledim
daha henüz yavaş yavaş geliyor şimdi Eee
Genom dizisi çok önemli Genom dizisi Eee
bugüne kadar 2001 yılında yani Genom
dizinini 100 milyon dolara bir insanın
100 milyon dolara
çıkabiliyorsun da Genom umuzun sadece
0.1 ini Eee ölçümle
eee
23 23 and me diye bir web sitesi var
ilginizi çekebilir 129 dolara
akrabalarınızın Eee çok rahatlıkla
ortaya çıkarıyor Peki
204550 geldiğimizde ölümsüzlük Eee yavaş
yavaş ortaya çıkıyor Biz hep robotlara
bilincimizi yüklüyorum yok Kalbimiz
bilmem ne insanlar farkına vardı abi biz
uzun yaşayalım ya Peki uzun yaşamak için
Eee obri the Grey sens dediğimiz
tasarlanmış ihmal edilebilir yaşlanma
stratejilerinin gelişiminde çalışıyor
amaç insan bedeninin yaşlanmasını
durdurmak Eee kurs While 2030'a
geldiğinde insan hafızasını Eee
internete yüklemeye başlayacağını
düşünüyor dolayısıyla biraz sonra
enteresan bir şey söyleyeceğim bugün 30
yaşında olanların ölümsüz olma şansı %
bizim pek şansımız yok yani Benim yaş
Grubumuzun çok fazla şansımız yok bakın
sol tarafta ilan musk'ın yaptığı şey
yani beynimize çip takıyorlar sonunda
Yani hani covid zamanı aşıyla çip
takmadılar ama burada beynimize çipi
takacaklar bugün Shutter STA bile Search
ettiğinizde artık bununla ilgili
illüstrasyon bile başladı Yani beyin
dalgalarıyla
[Müzik]
uydudan haberleşiyor olmak zaten elan
musk'ın söylediği buydu Peki bu kadar
data ne olacak yani 20 25'e geldiğimizde
33 trilyon GB data toplanacak ama
enteresan bir şey bu bilgiyi DNA
molekülüne
yükleyebilirsin pon topuna bütün bu
bilgi sığacak Demek ki ileride bilgi
bilgi de bu anlamda şey yapacak nükleer
olmazsa olmaz arkadaşlar nükleer olmak
zorunda ama nükleer O büyük nükleer
santrallerden bahsetmiyoruz yani eee
füzyonda bahsetmiyoruz bizim
bahsettiğimiz Mini Nükleer santraller
Bunlar yaşamımıza girecekler kaçamayız
Eee Aksi takdirde işte Almanya'nın
halini gördük Eee yani Yeşil Enerji
falan bunlar Tabii ki güzel ama Emre
amadelik deri az olduğu için Eee ne
yazık ki yeterli değil aynı zamanda Eee
bu bu tür santraller Eee tükenmiş
uranyumun Eee Plütonyum ile birleşmesi
yani Es diğer Eee santrallerin
atıklarıyla çalıştığı için de aslında
tehlikeli falan değiller doğalgazla
Eee Enerji Üretim 220 dolar mew saati
ama nükleerle 60 dolara düşüyor Yani siz
sanayici olarak doğalgazdan elektrik
elde ediyorsunuz pil olarak da kuantum
Nano piller geliyor şu andaki pillerden
1000 kat daha güçlü Eee Benim de yurt
dışında Bu konuyla ilgili bir Amerika'da
yatırım var Evet Zero marginal cost
Society dediğimiz ceremi rifkin
hatırlıyorsunuz bir parti getir getirdi
Eee Danışman olarak pek uyuşmuyor ama
Eee şeye nesnelerin interneti bedava
enerji ve collaborative commons
dediğimiz aslında şu Aslında Eee
kapitalizmden uzaklaşmaya başlıyoruz
yavaş yavaş neden kapitalizmden ulaşmaya
uzaklaşmaya başlıyoruz Çünkü her şeyin
fiyatı gittikçe düşmeye başlıyor kar
marjı kalmıyor firmalar birleşecek Eee
her konuda 34 firma kalmaya başl aşacak
Dolayısıyla Eee özellikle şeyde Yani hem
lojistikte hem enerjide hem iletişimde
eee şey artacak e Ödeme şey maliyetler
düşecek netflix bakın ileride netflix
kendi filmlerini koymadığı sürece ayakta
kalamaz web 3.0a çıktığımızda aracı diye
bir şey yok arkadaşlar Uber diye bir şey
yok insanlar yani son kullanıcı ilk
kullanıcı otomatik olarak blok zinciri
Eee ve web3.0 aracılığıyla eee e
birbirleriyle
iletişebilir var karbon yakalama ve
depolama teknolojileri Türkiye'nin
yatırım yapması gereken bugün 120 Dolar
civarında e Avrupa 2026 da sınırda
karbon düzenlemesi başlıyor çimento
kimyasal elektrik alüminyum bilmiyorum
bu konu da hani Pr dışında neler
yapılıyor Türkiye'de ama Eee böyle bir
durum var Yani bizim Karbon ayak izi
konusuna önem vermemiz gerekiyor e
Mehmet Şimşek bakanımız söyledi karbon
vergisi de gelecek 2030'a kadar peki
siyaset bu yönetişimi düşüne yönetebilir
mi Ben Türkiye'den bahsetmiyorum
dünyadan bahsediyorum dünyaki hiçbir
siyasi ve siyaset bu değişimi yönetemez
bu değişime ayak uyduramaz D dünyada
siyasi partilerin bu değişimi yakalaması
imkansız taahhütler söyleyeni değil
inananı Bağlar bunu bunun hani bunun bir
espri olduğunu hatırlıyorsunuz ya Ben
kardeşim söylerim yani taahhüt ederim de
beni bağlamaz inananı Bağlar Çünkü
biliyorsunuz
Eee siyasiler bolca taahüt ederler Eee
yaşam bölgeselliği dönecek yani eee
benim geleceğimle ilgili kararı Eee
Türkiye'nin Eee Erzurum'da yaşayan bir
vatandaşımın vermesini ben kabul
etmiyorum yani doğru olmadığını
düşünüyorum kabul etmiyorum değil Eee
seve seve kabul ediyorum bu bu zamanda
Ama doğru olmadığını düşünüyorum
Dolayısıyla
Eee her birey kendi geleceği ile ilgili
kararı şey yapacak mevzuatın akıllı
kontratlar döndüğü yönetim ve
harcamaların anlık olarak onaylı ve
şeffaf olduğu merkeziyetsiz
lidersiz otonom yapılar doğru Eee
hareket edeceğiz devlet son olarak
denetim mekanizmasını sağlayacak sonra
da aramızdan ayrılacak Yani devletin
Eee en son yapacağı iş güvenliği
sağlamak ama kendi kendini yöneten bir
dünyaya doğru Eee gitmeye başlıyoruz
Eee Biz bir futurist Hang kurduk Ben
Millenium Project 1996'da kurulmuş
Birleşmiş Milletler Üniversitesi'nin
kurduğu bir e kurum e 2009 yılında
bağımsız hale geldi dünya çapında da 73
noda ulaştı Ben de Türkiye nodunun Eee
kurucusuyum Biz şimdi entelijansiya
Bilim Teknoloji ve Kalkınma politikaları
Merkezi diye bir tinten kurduk ne
yapacağız Biliyor musunuz arkadaşlar 13
Kalkınma planını yani 2029 Kalkınma
Planını bugünden hazırlayacağız Çünkü
2011 10'a baktığınızda 2012'de yeni
çıkıyor bu Kalkınma planlarının
Türkiye'ye hiçbir yararı yok sadece
siyasi söylemlere
aracılık ediyor ve bunları ben hiçbir
partiyi destekleyerek Ben zaten Parti
takım falan mümkün değil yani eee
entelijans org TR'ye girerek bize
katkıda bulunabilirsiniz Biz 500 kişiye
ulaştık böyle bir şey var mı 20 dakikada
bitirdim Hiç Deneme yapmadan süper
teşekkürler